almost 1/5 of the world's population has
no access to electricity so have to use
other means to heat and light their
homes which are often expensive
dangerous and unhealthy lamps filled
with kerosene are the main source of
light in households in the developing
world
but living with one of these over the
course of the day is the equivalent to
smoking 40 cigarettes Jim Reeves and his
team think they have a solution they've
designed a light that is powered by
gravity and has no running costs we were
presented with the challenge of trying
to developer a viable alternative to
kerosene lanterns for our Solar charity
and we came up with a solution of
gravity light which uses a lifted weight
in the same way sort of principle has
been used for the generations to drive
things like their grandfather clocks
rather than the two or three minutes it
takes to charge a wind-up light to
charge gravity light it takes just three
seconds for 30 minutes of light the user
lifts the 10 kilogram bag then a series
of gears turn powering a low-cost
generator which turns the light on no
fuel is needed just the effort of
lifting the bag it's hoped it will sell
for under $10 it's been four and a half
years in the making and gone through
lots of iterations but a thousand units
are now being trialed in 26 countries
purpose of the trial is partly to
understand
NEADS as if as a concept but also to
understand what kind of rigors and
challenges that the system is going to
have to withstand one man who's managed
to make a successful international
business already is the founder of
children's case company trunky I asked
him for his take on the light I think
it's very interesting concept I think
the real key for all physical product
that is going to sell it and do well in
developing markets is that they're able
to be fixed by the local people so if it
breaks it can be serviced without
overseas components we're very mindful
of the fact that for the device to be
really as long-lived as it could be and
the idea of having serviceable parts is
almost essential we're looking in the in
the medium term at either starting with
some in-country assembly ultimately
perhaps in country manufacturer gravity
light has the potential to lift millions
out of poverty but the next challenge is
bringing it to scale to make it
affordable for all